welcome to this video playing is a
gladiator this is either Hoffman author
of a recently released book on the chick
benoni so the Trump hi sorry I very
aggressively minded yep okay I'm just
accepting this trans position to a
French I wonder if we had that and
somehow somehow rings a bell that is a
French structure not but a position that
usually wouldn't be reached from a
French so it's um somewhat different and
right there three yeah that was my idea
if I've gaining some space he's got
Knight c3 down now Kim I can do that
playing g6 h5 5784 those standard moves
I have blacks idea oh no I cannot do
that like that Diaz to establish a night
on c4 ok taking over them and that was
close really i was close to playing as
night c4 as a move now
yeah I'll do this first probably a move
I need anyway if I go right in five now
nights seven nights you for that cannot
be bad really I think as also night be
three yeah I 93 I could have done that
anyway here before King g7 even I mean
okay so he's giving up some material
curious even night c4 is the move but i
think i think i will take the exchange I
really I don't know said enough
compensation and he's got some i mean
this is this is this is a clear
basically it's not just an exchange for
absolutely nothing ok go here try to
trade if i get to see for I don't oopsie
695 I guess
you
yeah maybe the smooth 497 yeah like 97
and queen f8 and along these lines
Knight f6 it's also an idea
maybe just this trying to trade things
we should be five in particular if he
goes like 22 I have you should be five I
believe there should be a good a good
way to simplify things
I don't see how he keeps that pawn
really if I take you five and then
Quincy six or something like that that
should be winning check here I would
like to do it without taking actually if
possible I cannot get ff6 could have 67
the night goes back I go Quincy for that
same know now that we win the porn yeah
and it's a fairly safe position
keep that pawn and how do we win may be
Queen over to reform when naija nights
to UM lie to you for would be great of
course if I can get that in
yeah I'm just keeping everything
together here by night on d 7 this is
the key the key improvement if I get it
into the game I will win and probably
rather easily let's see let's do this
not necessary really okay night / this
video via d6s esta Kiki IDM I don't
think that he can push further check
check
yeah 1 million 14 enough time to convert
the material so I don't need your check
and rush in particular white resides hmm
yeah I don't know that was an
interesting French type of position yeah
I've played this kind of setup with
black quite a bit when I was still
playing the French a long time ago
hopefully 20 years or so and yeah I
never really did that well yeah but I
really not really not sure what white
should do I mean in the cases where I
didn't work for me I mostly got a check
mijita door someone sprung in a check on
me quickly on g6 or something for
example this yeah let's just try to take
if I go now here maybe 95 intending to
take it sits
check that's very scary I don't know I
probably probably has something around
him like this yeah I could have played
95 already the move Queen d2 is probably
a mistake as it runs into the fork on b3
enters Knight to c4 move and i think yes
to go Queenie to now keep the material I
would probably do something like this
and I definitely have from games in the
last couple of moves but I'm not better
or anything
errg I'm just material up i don't think
that wide missed any any particular
joins you felt like pretty solid
conversion so yeah i'm satisfied i think
that was okay the opening was shaky but
afterwards it was a decent game thanks
for watching